[Music]
um
we're upstairs thanks
it's good to see you again something
happened
come on jeff will explain everything
he's just about done prepping for the
debate i've rescheduled all his meetings
out of the office today
the office meeting here so nobody will
bother us
um bother us at doing what we're talking
about the cornerstone of my platform
i'm not doing a u-turn just cause
nightcore no i'm not sucking anyone's
dick just so they can [ __ ] me in the ass
[Music]
look i gotta go make the amendments
we'll pow out later
v glad you can make it jefferson
grab a seat please i'll explain why i
asked you to come over
[Music]
shall we
we've had a break-in not the usual kind
though
so unusual how a couple of days back
dead of night something wakes me a noise
i grab my pistol and come out of the
bedroom see a stranger
he looks like he's about to reach for it
so i pull the trigger
nail him no idea my head started
spinning and i passed down
no trace of him the morning after i'd
like you to find him
find out what he wanted
why me of all people would you rather
have a detective look into it
prefer to use tried and tested contacts
can't blame you
former mayor's death you unraveled that
mystery
i trust you'll be able to crack this one
as well
notify the badges yet we don't want any
buzz around this
no attention whatever you know
ncpd is full of people who like the
occasional stray eddy
if we reported a break in the media
descend on us like a swarm of locusts
no badges gotcha of course we notified
ssi
about the incident our private security
intruder take anything uh break anything
nothing missing i haven't noticed any
damage either
jeff must have scared him off before he
could do anything
intruder take anything nothing missing
i haven't noticed any
said you passed out
that's right what then
nothing i woke up in bed the next
morning
killer headache taboo any idea how you
made it back to your bed
no none
what did the intruder look like i can't
remember much
it was dark he was wearing some sort of
mask
or was it an implant i couldn't really
get a good look at him
elizabeth didn't see him either i slept
through the whole thing
election season takes its toll on you
security looking at this say anything
this is where things get a little weird
they
claim there's no sign of a break-in or
of a shot being fired
security cams didn't record anything
guard outside didn't see her
hear anything they suggested jeff must
have had a bad dream
convenient answer liz gave security the
day off
so i could call you in this um security
outfit
ssi who are they
been on the market the last 15 years
they have clients across the city
if memory serves they came recommended
in acquaintance you think ssi might be
behind this
no clue yet anyone besides ssi come to
mind readily
malden holt he did kill the last mayor
and the polls do have him trailing jeff
but
it could be anyone really jeff has many
enemies a lot of them powerful we could
sit here naming names all day
i see that's why i called you v
i need you to find out what the hell's
going on
anything else you want to tell me or
you think you maybe should
nope that about covered it liz
it seems like everything it's unlikely
we'll learn anything anyway
honey please i'm sure veal turns
something up
so you've got all you need for now
wouldn't mind taking a look around the
apartment
of course let's give you the tour gotta
run to a meeting as soon as you learn
anything
let me know
come on let me show you around
oh rather poke around my own way
you mind no of course not
i'll be right behind you in case
you're welcome to go to the roof want
i'll wait here
sure thing
odd tech's practically prehistoric
but it doesn't look older than a day saw
something like this back in the war
transmitters militech was using them
short range uhf signal only travels line
of sight
but it can't be intercepted line of
sight
let's look around see if we can't spot
where our receiver's camping out
got a vision the receiver black van
parked next to it
gotta be our winner the hell is all this
for though
[ __ ] if i know but my gut tells me we
should see what this bad boy's hooked up
to
see these cables
sharp eye johnny
for yourself
okay
kingdom
you and jefferson you've come a long way
to get from haywood all the way here
it's no easy thing
yes if you aren't born with a silver
shard your chances are slim
and if you're born in haywood they're
almost non-existent
[Music]
jeff's office control rooms a happy
family
that your daughter sachi
oh i miss her her studies took her
abroad
oh we do europe
an excellent school she'll get a good
education
i know it's an ocean away but with jeff
running for mayor
it's just safer this way
tight bites you and jeff must be putting
in serious overtime
elections you don't even have time to
think about food so you just order
whatever's quickest
but yes it's true jeff hasn't eaten
anything else recently
so
this is jeff's personal machine i doubt
you'll find anything on it relating to
the break-in
[Music]
wedding pic interesting backdrop
i wanted blue roses this is where we
sleep
blue roses what you sure cause the roses
in this picture look pretty red to me
oh of course you're right they didn't
have blue roses i forgot
iron this jeff's
mine actually but yes that's the one
jeff used that night
blood stains not quite scrubbed clean
where's the blood from it yours
i'm 100 sure it's not ours
maybe the intruders probably
so
broken it was fine a couple days ago
we rarely use it though
what was that no [ __ ] clue
felt kind of good but weird like
tripping on acid
that happened to the screen a lot or to
any of the others
i don't understand what just happened a
second ago
didn't see it no
what okay never mind
[Music]
this was my den before the campaign a
place
to focus relax doesn't look it anymore
security had to set up somewhere
one of the many small sacrifices i've
had to make
this was the first but it won't be the
last
[Music]
[Music]
looks like ssi's employees knew about
the break-in
fresh fruit tasty by the looks of it
they deliver it to us it's included
looks like it's been enhanced
what have we got here glutamine
noradrenaline
dopamine serotonin all new
transmitters know anything about this
it's smart food it's enhanced for
improved mental performance
i don't know if it really works but
people believe it
other than that it isn't half bad
fresh fruit from rotting vegetables
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
jesus christ i think we're safe putting
your security at the top of our list of
[Music]
suspects
they violated our privacy sons of
[ __ ]
under my own roof i wonder how long
they've been keeping this from me
too long this ends now i'm not letting
any more of those freaks set
foot ah my head
something wrong don't worry about me
do what you have to do
use the meds intruder make a beeline
here after jeff tagged him
talking to yourself again more and more
ever since this terrorist started
stalking me
[Music]
weird homeware what's it for
[Music]
connected to the wall mounted screens
wonder where else these cables run
transmitters within reach of our mystery
van
wonder if elizabeth has ever seen the
car
there's a transmitter on the roof it
seems to be conveying a signal to a van
out front
you know who it might be we never set up
any transmitter
and i don't know a thing about any van
but my guess is it's ssis
could be tech they're using seems
unconventional though
do you plan to check it yeah about to
pay them a personal visit
i'll wait here just don't tell jeff
anything for now
okay sure whatever i'll call him once i
know something more substantial
that's fine just remember it's the
busiest time for jeff right now
you can always come and talk to me fine
i'll keep that in mind
[Music]
[Music]
if
[Music]
[Music]
um
ah
[Music]
uh
so
hey
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
how about we take the wheels v that van
could give us a slip any second
[Music]
um
[Music]
get the latest trusted scoop on night
city only on
54 news
[Music]
let's go
um
it's desired
involved
it's
administration
thank you
oh
[Music]
um
[Applause]
is
[Music]
nc back with you soon
foreign
maybe
um
thank you
i'm so disrespectful and this here
i'm so disrespectful man
okay
[Music]
you don't believe in no faith
gonna lose him if you don't pick up the
pigs
they could be corporal spies or who the
[ __ ] knows
my son my turf my block my voice my
wrists my back
my gash they strapped all black all
trapped in myself for the rest
of politicians and see a curated display
but behind the scenes
they spy on all the paralysis look for
weak spots
gang
pierced it we're in couldn't ask the
ncpd
for better records than this pictures
medical records vulnerability to
neuroplasticity
some kind of database brain scans the
paralysis
biological casts neuroplasticity
[ __ ] what about that the blue [ __ ]
fresh neural links they're not spying on
them johnny they're [ __ ] with their
heads
i mean to say someone's literally
controlling our upstanding politicians
minds
red bloods are memory residue in the
hippocampus region
see how they're bleeding into the blue
so what are we looking at
they're planting new memories in their
heads modifying their personalities
this is big [ __ ] johnny [ __ ] me
got other guinea pigs besides the
paralysis too
quick download the data whoever comes
looking for it
that's your suspect [ __ ] they're wiping
the data
we've been made now they know someone's
been in their database
wonder if they also know who
um
v do you have any news
finish this another time
[Music]
ah
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you're here i know you are
as you were saying v do you news
okay you're gonna want to sit down for
this it's
um it's way bigger than we thought
what is you're being brainwashed
literally they've
you and i we need to speak alone
i know a little ramen place in japan
town sending you the coordinates
right see you there
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
so
and see back with you so soon how's your
afternoon
the name aaron mccarlson ring a bell
sergeant in the ncpd
yeah he's a great a bastard but has
proven some effectiveness
he put three maelstrom gangs behind bars
yesterday
and shot another two who resisted arrest
a dirty cop's not normally one deserving
of my praise but
hey a little dirt's okay
so
[Music]
mmm
let's max
hey will you sit right thank you for
coming
in paris their next stop is on your
doorstep
why are we meeting here and not at your
path
because i have something to confess in
private
not in front of jeff okay confess away
i i'm sorry my nerves are shot i can't
gather my thoughts
wasn't that long ago since we last met
something
happened since then no i mean
something did happen though not recently
it's a long story i don't quite know how
to tell you
where to even start
relax no need to rush
ah uh uh a while ago
i started noticing some changes in
jeff's behavior
his personality he seemed to be
changing right in front of me becoming
someone else
he stopped reading forgot the title of
his favorite movie
even his musical taste changed overnight
once i said we should visit his
brother's grave
and he told me that he'd been an only
child
that's when i started thinking something
bad was happening
something insidious
and not just with jeff
notice any changes in yourself
after some time on several occasions my
friends pointed out that i was acting
strangely
that must have been hard it was
you know it's at times like those you
start to question reality
so the whole time you knew what i could
end up finding
i don't know who how or why but they're
changing us that concealed room in our
apartment
what about it i'm sure i'd seen it
before but
must have somehow forgotten
i find that terrifying
mention any of this to jeff
i tried i did but he's blinded to
everything
he just laughed said i was imagining
things
he once brought up a vacation that we
never went on
swear to god he went on about it in such
detail
i almost started believing him it could
be just you who forgot
maybe they wiped the trip from your
memory hell i don't know anymore
don't you get that you haven't told me
the whole story yet have you
i saw a stranger in our apartment one
night tinkering with the monitors
but i was in such a state by then that i
didn't know if i could trust my own eyes
so you didn't do anything i don't
remember what happened
i talked to security the next morning
[Music]
i find it strange you took this to
security instead of your husband
i thought i was going insane i wanted to
see what was on the feeds first
there was nothing there of course so
what was i supposed to tell jeff
and then the next day
whoever they are there was a
garbled voice on the other end he never
introduced himself
and you cut some kind of deal with him
no i was told that our perfect lives
could fall apart
at any minute that i have my husband's
safety to think about
after there was no record of the call
it was as if it had never happened so
i'm begging you v
jefferson can't find out about any of
this
ever his life depends on it
[Music]
you think if i tell him everything that
he'll go and pick a fight he can't win
i don't just think i know one thing
hasn't changed
jeff's still a fighter and he'll go down
swinging
so how do we play this i'm going to tell
jeff
that ssi was spying for his rival holt
you just need to confirm what i say
truly prepared to fire ssi after the
threats
and to be brave but risky is all get out
what they're doing to us is one thing
but when you found that concealed room
i can't accept strangers spying on us
while we sleep
not under my own roof what difference
does it make
where i'll take full responsibility for
anything ssi goes on to do
i'm just asking you not to get jefferson
involved
i'll add a meeting in reconciliation
park to jeff's schedule
he'll be waiting since i can't know if
i'll remember this conversation tomorrow
i'm counting on you not to forget what i
asked of you
i won't that's all i can promise
goodbye v
all things [ __ ] up huh wouldn't want
to be in herpen
speaking of overlapping memories
changing personalities
remind you of anything but hey at least
we know what we're up against
[Music]
so in my pants what would you do
some real rat bastards behind this
someone's got to take them down even by
risking the paralysis lives
[ __ ] knows what kind of [ __ ] a mare
controlled by puppet masters could pull
but yeah you could end up putting their
lives at risk
or not tough choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
foreign
yeah it doesn't matter what you tell him
it doesn't matter what you think of
doing or do
you can't change anything yeah
what we know who you are we know what
you are
we know what you want you are playing
with fire
don't dare cross the line
oh [ __ ]
hmm
do we know each other
[Music]
the nscpd advises those traveling beyond
official police jurisdictions
hello
need to talk yes
i know elizabeth field media
sounds like i was right to hire a
professional
what did she tell you exactly
didn't get specific just that ssi was
spying for that son of a [ __ ]
guess you got more though
ssi wasn't working for holt you're in
deeper [ __ ] than you think
meaning
they're in your heads jefferson yours
and elizabeth's this some kind of
chuckle-worthy metaphor strange dreams
partial recall jumbled memories it's not
just stress and long hours
i don't know what you're trying to tell
me but i don't think i like where this
is heading
wake up your brain's a mess messier than
the discount section of a bd smut
i'm not paying you to make up riddles
for me so get to the point
ssi's on the take for some unknown group
that's out to control your lives
you know there's concealed room in your
pad
out with it they've got tech in there
you wouldn't believe
these people know everything about you
and your wife
they're watching your every move
[Music]
somebody's programming you and your wife
sounds like something out of the movies
i saw your brain scans
they're tweaking your neural connections
this ain't no movie jeff
banana for a while you and liz editing
your memories your tastes
your views and beliefs even how could i
not have known about this
your memories can't even trust those
anymore
if that's true i'll never know what's
real in my life and what's a lie
fabricated wait the intruder
i have to find him
got no idea how we go about doing that
first i'll find him then i'll find
whoever's behind this
pull the curtain back on these
[ __ ] and show them what's what
or use your mayoral powers if you get
elected
as long as you don't forget all this by
morning
sun tzu's art of war vain weakness
so your enemy may grow arrogant don't
see you doing much
feigning jeff my god
i have to tell liz
your wife knows everything liz
howe figured it out at some point
elizabeth no no no no
she would have said something
she feared for your life your daughter's
life
who could blame her no
no she's never kept anything for me and
she doesn't scare
easily believe me got an anonymous
hollow telling her to keep her mouth
shut
so she did what the perfect candidate's
wife would do
protected her family
[Music]
i won't let them get away with this
is there anything else i can do you've
done enough already v
all that's left to do is wait
so what now still want to be mayor
well i'm not about to give up i didn't
run just
i'll wait for my window an opportunity
then make my move isn't that exactly
what they want
well i'll give them more than they
bargained for same theoreties
take care of me good luck and
good night so
thoughts somehow i doubt it's people who
are behind this
so aliens very funny
you're too young to remember this but
not so long ago people talked about
rogue ai's prowling cyberspace
so not aliens doesn't matter who what
matters is that guy decided to take up
the gun
my man protect him from the competition